[Music]
[Applause]
you guys welcome to the amber ruffin
show the amber ruffin show is the only
late night show that's sponsored by kale
kale it's collard greens for white
people
eat that [ __ ] up i don't know why we are
coming to you tonight from studio 8g in
rockefeller center with a live studio
audience
yeah damn right woo
our audience is all vaccinated all
masked and all about that base about
that base no treble
in addition to a studio audience we also
have a terry davis
say hi to the audience hey audience
what are you getting your mother for
mother's day this sunday that's this
sunday yep
oh
tarek
you guys
it's been a crazy week in america let's
find out what happened
president biden on monday celebrated the
muslim holiday idol fitter at the white
house and then republicans demanded to
see his birth certificate
archaeologists recently found a 1 000
year old cave drawing in alabama even
crazier this was the drawing
grace's cave always been around
me no want you in me neighborhood
he just want equal opportunity
[Laughter]
you say equal but you mean special
benefits
why can't we oh just get along
tune into our show
racist cavemen
wednesdays on nbc
authorities in new york city are
searching for a man who allegedly stole
125 thousand dollars from an eye doctor
safe now if you know anything please
call this number
according to a recent report the u.s bra
market is now more than 50 percent
free bras what's a wire free bra said
women over size b
thank you
someone's got some big boobies out there
and they enjoyed that joke
the 2022 american mensah mind games were
last weekend the winner was my ex
what does he want
riddle me this ambi
i've been thinking of you
and i have a girlfriend
[Laughter]
sound like that i used to date the
riddler oh
oh okay sorry
ah
you lived in gotham city for a little
bit i did i did i did too much crime
a four-year-old in the netherlands last
weekend reportedly took his mom's car
for a drive after his dad went to work
find out more in boss baby three too
fast too curious yeah
eeyore's birthday was last weekend
not that anyone cared
and finally a startup company in north
carolina is trying to make lab-grown
human milk and like real human milk you
can get it in jugs
that was the monologue did you like the
monologue
then
we made it from the freshest ingredients
moving on
this week the website politico obtained
a draft of a supreme court opinion
indicating the court intends to overturn
the landmark case roe versus wade
after the news broke supreme court chief
justice john roberts announced an
investigation into how the document was
leaked at this point nobody knows if it
was a liberal clerk or a conservative
clerk or even just one of the actual
justices it's a total mystery which is
why i'm excited to announce that we
actually have the anonymous leaker
joining us right now via satellite
but this is some high level [ __ ] so we
had to agree to protect this person's
identity so please welcome the anonymous
supreme court leaker
thank you for having me amber
thanks for joining us now let's cut to
the chase everyone in america wants to
know who you are and why you did this
what can you tell us about your identity
virtually nothing i took a major risk
leaking this decision and it's not an
exaggeration to say that my life is in
danger
so you can't tell us anything about who
you are nothing
in fact i'm even lowering the natural
pitch of my voice to ensure my identity
remains hidden
that's not a voice modulator no it's all
me i can't take any chances
that's a bummer because finding out your
identity would be a big scoop for the
show i mean
i guess we can assume you work in the
supreme court
well okay yeah i guess that goes without
saying so that means you probably went
to harvard not necessarily hmm well
anyone who went to harvard can't resist
telling other people they went to
harvard so
okay yeah i went to harvard
are you a democrat or a republican i'm
not answering that man woman or
non-binary there is no such thing as
non-binary okay so you're clearly a
republican man
so someone is what's your ethnicity i'm
not answering that either
well what do you think of the beatles
they're all musical geniuses okay so
you're white damn it okay so let's see
you're a white republican man who went
to harvard and works at the supreme
court please don't reveal my identity
don't worry i just described pretty much
every single person who works at the
supreme court i guess you're just gonna
have to remain anonymous forever thank
god oh no my real voice they're all
gonna know my real voice i'm down
the anonymous leaker everyone
i
i i think that was ian that was that was
easy i think that was ian yeah the
writer
anonymously yeah he works at the supreme
court when he's not here wow
i feel like he should have told me but
okay
the news that the supreme court will
likely overturn roe v wade is the
biggest news of the week and frankly
it's infuriating i'm honestly at a loss
for words so here to comment please
welcome one of my writers corinne wells
thanks amber what we know so far is
interesting now
is it true that
i'm glad you asked amber
[Laughter]
sources are saying that
ah
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
look
all jokes aside
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
ah
that's right
korin i could not have said it better
myself
what just happened
[Music]
you